big new topic hooray so this will be I
hope you'll find a bit of a breath of
fresh air after parametric's which a lot
of people find just confusing and a lot
of intense algebra we sort of dial back
a little bit and say okay relax
this concept as a whole is generally
easier to wrap your head around however
it goes some really really important
places so it's not as though things are
getting easier it's just a temporary
break for your brain while we get you
going for the next thing so this is the
heading there's the date got this down
already because I was a bit more
organized today we are interested in a
particular kind of new object actually a
whole bunch of them that are related
together there are three and I'm going
to explain them in order which as you'll
see in a second is quite ironic so even
though it's not in the title here the
best place to start in this topic is
with an object a mathematical object
called a set it's a really really simple
kind of object all it means is you
collect a bunch of things in fact a
collection is a good way to define or a
good synonym for a set you got a bunch
of items they could literally be
anything they could be a bunch of
numbers a bunch of functions a bunch of
shapes anything you want
all that matters is that you've got a
bunch of them and you put them in a big
pile okay that's what a set is now where
it's nice to hit the rubber hits the
road for this topic is where you say
well let's take that collection of
things and let's put them in some kind
of order so a sequence is a set that has
an order to it a set with order so for
instance here's a set it's a black
marker and a red marker and a blue
marker okay here's a set no matter which
way you look at it it's still the same
set you know nothing's changed but for
me to say okay let's make a sequence of
markers this sequence here
blue black and red is different from
this sequence here black blue and red
right so all that matters here when we
talk about sequences is all right now it
matters which order I place these in and
that's what makes this a sequence we're
not going to get into a series until a
little bit later in this topic but it
makes sense to talk about them now in
this context which is that a serious is
what happens when you take a bunch of
object in the sequence and then you add
them up that's all it means if you add
everything in a sequence together you
get a series okay now each of these we
indicate with notation in its own ways
so for instance a set you'll see a bunch
of a pair of curly braces so for example
1 2 7 3 something like that if I were to
say make that into a sequence I could
say 1 comma 2 comma 7 comma 3 so when
you don't have the curly braces there
it's like Oh suddenly order here is
important these two sets 3 7 1 2 would
be the same set but if I were to write 3
7 1 2 now the order is different they're
not the same sequence how would I turn
this into a series instead of writing
commas I'm just gonna have plus signs
right so 1 plus 2 plus 7 plus 3 there
you go
okay now since in each of these cases
right there's this idea of moving
forward through the sequence or moving
forward through the series whereas with
a set there's no forward or backward
there's no there's no first or last part
because these parts sort of have a
forward and backward we have a synonym
that covers synonyms not the right word
for it and we have a category that
covers both of them we call these guys
progressions because you can progress
from one term to the next